this is probably the most fortified
office in the world right now and we've
been asked not to film anything which
could give away the position or the
layout Behind These multiple layers of
security they're guarding the man Most
Wanted by Russian troops and Vladimir
Putin
he's speaking to about 10 world leaders
a day and gets by on four hours of sleep
a night
hi Mr President Alex Crawford from Sky
News UK thank you very much thanks for
giving us the time I know you must be
exhausted but surrounded by his Security
in a heavily barricaded office the
Ukrainian president is bristling with
energy and as a former actor he knows
very well the power of the media and how
essential it is to get his message out
yeah so first of all just want to know
how you are how are you feeling the
House of Commons oh you see I think I'm
feeling like all the ukrainians we are
feeling
strong
a long pause because he's also clearly
frustrated at the world's response
We Can't Stop alone of this
no do you think it is
only if the world will unite around
Ukraine around United around Ukraine
they are not there still is it's still
very slowly it's still very slowly but
you can feel it only when you are here
because the people from Europe or USA
it's far from Ukraine far from the heart
of this tragedy and and you you can't
see you you can't understand the details
because you are not fighting here and I
understand why and I don't want them to
fight but these countries can help can
Unite
we are speaking about closing the sky
you can't decide to close or not to
close you can't decide if you are United
against the Nazism and this Terror you
have to close not me don't wait me
asking you several times a lot million
times close the sky no you have to phone
us to our people who lost their children
and say sorry we didn't do it yesterday
one week ago we didn't push Putin we
didn't speak with him a lot we didn't
found find the dialogue with him we we
we did nothing and it's true yesterday
the world did nothing I'm sorry but it's
true now a lot of countries
at least hear us and now close the sky
and stop bombing don't don't speak about
the bureaucratic steps and we have we
have united we have have United decision
we can have sit down and vote in the
parliaments we don't have so much time
the rest of the governments as I
understand it think it will become worse
if they involve themselves actively so
it would be was for whom
for our families no
for them
know who knows nobody knows but but we
know exactly that now is very bad
and in future it will be too late and
believe me believe me if if it's
prolonged this way yes you will see they
will close the sky
but will lose millions of people
they're preparing to fight even in the
president's office and he claims the
Russian bombing of hospitals shows the
mark of the enemy they want us to feel
like animals because they blocked our
cities the biggest cities in Ukraine and
they blocked and and because they don't
want our our people to get some food
water yesterday for example children I
don't know if if you know the children
in marupal was the child was dead the
idea you grow do with ukrainians animals
but but we are not that that's it is it
possible to do a deal with the Russians
or not it doesn't sound like it will be
very difficult yeah anyway it will be
very difficult but but it's true that I
will try and we'll see but not only on
my not it's it's not the story about you
know it's not fairy tale the serious
things it's not about my own decision
it's the decision of two countries and
two peoples yes and and the decision of
two presence and one of them is Putin so
we'll see well what happens if you say
do you if you go if you president
zielinski leave with Putin says
president zielinski go then we can stop
the War I love my country and I know
that was one of the ideas and not my
ideas I don't know I don't want to speak
whose ideas but I know exactly that if I
lived
my office and my country my people I
think that it would be very difficult
for our country it would be very
difficult to unite our country it would
be very difficult to have strong people
we have strong Army but it would be very
difficult to unite people and Army and
to unite all our nation that's why I
think my decision was right I think so
who knows we'll see in future you may
not give up but can you actually win
against a much bigger force it will
never be Russians if the idea to do us
Russians the idea is
not not great so it will fail and so you
can occupy it of course all the big
countries can occupy it a little bit
smaller countries or very small
countries there are a lot of countries
which Russia can occupy that is that is
the idea of Nazism you think they
wouldn't ever agree to any Russian
um
proxy I said I mean yeah instead of you
and it stopped the war so there's no
more you don't you don't think the
people would agree to that I think first
of all that is the decision not my and
not Putin that is the decision of
Ukrainian Nation who is the president of
Ukraine I think so
okay thank you bye-bye his staff is
anxious we're too long in one place he
says they have priorities
I'm keeping this president alive is
number one Alex Crawford Sky News Keith